I’m on fire somebody stop me
I’m going crazy and my body’s heating up
Following the rhythm my body is on fire
that I could burn the roof down
I can’t help myself whenever there is music
I just can’t stay still, I go crazy
When the lights go crazy, I go crazy
There must be something in my blood,
filled with something toxic
Somebody please get me out of this wicked body
Oh baby baby baby please
I’m on fire somebody stop me
I’m going crazy and my body’s heating up
Following the rhythm my body is on fire
that I could burn the roof down
Where's the party?
Where’s the party?
People at first sight think that I’m crazy
I just can’t stay still, I go crazy
They think I’m either drunk or drugged
Don’t know why I am like this
Sometimes I'm surprised at myself
Surely I’m not crazy but I look like a crazy
Baby oh baby, baby please
I’m on fire somebody stop me
I’m going crazy and my body’s heating up
Following the rhythm my body is on fire
that I could burn the roof down
I could die in this madness,
but actually that's a great way to die
Anyone who wants to fall into the music
and get out of control please join me
I’m on fire somebody stop me
I’m going crazy and my body’s heating up
Following the rhythm my body is on fire
that I could burn the roof down
Where's the party?
Where’s the party?